LaLa Cour qui a décidé que
c'c'était inconstitutionnel.
DoDonc, à partir de maintenant
c'c'est terminé, il y en aura
plplus. Réaction de Maître Jean-
ClClaude Hébert, avocat spécialé
enen droit criminel,
bobonsoir Me H Hébert.
- - Bonsoir, Madame.
- - On a l'impression que derrie
cecela, c'est vraiment une visin
dede la justice qui est très
didifférente de celle des
coconservateurs du gouvernement
HaHarper de 2011 qui a été
dédébattue entre les juges
dede la Cour suprême et c'est
unune décision unanime, aussi.
QuQu'est-ce que vous décodez
dederrière cela?
- - Vous avez raison de dire
ququ'il y a eu une profonde
réréflexion auprès des juges pae
quque si on retourne un petit pu
enen arrière, à l'époque où le
jujuge Antonio Lamer était juge
enen chef, il y avait une forte
didiscussion sur la façon
d'd'interpréter, de façon
éqéquilibrée, cette dispositionà
dede l'article 12 de la Charte
dedes droits, et il n'y avait ps
nénécessairement l'espèce d'unié
ququi rejoignait tous les juges.
OnOn s'aperçoit qu'au passage du
tetemps, on a commencé, évidemmt
ilil y a des nouveaux juges
àà la Cour, on a commencé à
s's'intéresser davantage à cette
didisposition-là pour lui donner
plplus de porter. On la fait
enen 2016, quand on a rejeté
lala validité de certaines
pepeines minimales. Ensuite,
lele gouvernement fédéral a pris
lele relais et il a fait
unun projet de loi pour s'attaqr
auaux peines minimales. Et là,
vovous avez le summum, c'est-à-
didire, la Cour suprême, qui di:
"C"C'est le temps de prendre
unune position uniforme" et c'et
lala vertu de ce jugement-là,
auau moins il n'y a pas
d'd'indécision pour les citoyen,
popour les juristes, pour les
trtribunaux. On connaît les règs
dudu jeu maintenant et c'est
clclarifié.
- - Oui, et au coeur de cela,
vrvraiment, c'est le concept qun
inindividu doit avoir une chance
dede se réhabiliter, finalement?
- - Oui et pour asseoir solidemt
cecette analyse-là, la Cour
sese réfère à ce qu'on appelle
lele concept de dignité. Cherchz
papas dans la Charte des droits
lala mention de ce concept-là,
çaça n'existe pas. Mais la Cour
a a dit : "Il reste quand même e
cocondamner quelqu'un à mourir n
prprison, ça porte un sacré coup
àà la dignité de la personne et
onon trouve que c'est contraire
dede pas lui donner une petite
ououverture au bout de ses 25 as
dede détention sur la possibilié
dede retourner avec les citoyen,
vivivre une vie normale",
etet c'est ça qui est le concep.
C'esest un concept très à la moe
dedepuis qu'on s'intéresse à
momourir dans la dignité. Il y a
eueu beaucoup de chemin parcouru
etet j'ai l'impression que la Cr
susuprême a profité de l'occasin
popour dire : "Ça c'est un conct
imimportant et on veut lui donnr
dudu tonus."
- - Mais il faut aussi comprende
quque ce n'est pas automatique
lala libération au bout de 25 a.
OnOn a le droit de faire
unune demande au bout de 25 ans,
mamais ça ne veut pas dire
ququ'on va acquiescer à notre
dedemande et ça veut pas dire,
cocomme certains le redoutent,
quque des criminels vont se
reretrouver dans la rue par
lala suite?
- - Non, vous avez raison de
lele signifier, c'est très
imimportant de le rappeler.
EtEt quand on regarde l'histoire
pépénible de nos grands crimines
auau Canada, je pense, par
exexemple, à Robin Pickton en
CoColombie-Britannique, qui a
cacausé la mort d'autochtones, e
fefemmes autochtones, il a été,
jeje ne sais pas combien de foi,
dedevant la Commission
dedes libérations conditionnell,
etet à chaque fois, sa demande
ététait refusée, rejetée.
EtEt, je pense également à
d'd'autres grands criminels,
ouoù à Toronto, il y en a eu
plplusieurs...
- - Bernardo, entre autres.
- - Ils sont toujours rejetés,
ououi. Les demandes sont toujous
rerejetées. Et, bon, ça veut pas
didire qu'elles ne le seront
totoutes un jour, si quelqu'un
cocomme Bissonnette, qui était
trtrès jeune quand les incidents
sese sont produits, va évidemmet
mamaturé, évolué, et dans 25 ans
d'd'ici, je suis convaincu que
cece ne sera plus le même homme.
LeLes commissaires de cette
épépoque-là auront à réviser
soson dossier et à examiner.
C'C'est ça l'espoir de vie,
c'c'est ça la dignité.
- - Quand vous entendez
leles conservateurs dire :
"o"on trouve ça décevant pour
leles victimes, cette décision-,
onon n'est pas d'accord avec
lala décision de la Cour suprêm,
ququelle est votre réaction?
PaParce que c'est comme si
onon opposait les victimes
etet le criminel et son droit
dede faire une réflexion sur
cece qu'il a fait, éventuellemet
dede changer et peut-être,
évéventuellement, un jour d'être
lilibéré?
- - La Cour d'appel du Québec,
ququi avait rendu un grand
jujugement bien étoffé sur
cecette question-là, est allée
didirectement sur le sujet
enen disant : "C'est pas
unun objectif valable que
dede faire de la vengeance.
SiSi on veut venger la douleur
dedes victimes, de la famille
dedes victimes, c'est pas
l'l'objectif noble d'infliction
d'd'une peine, surtout une peine
dede 25 ans." Alors, on peut fae
dede la justice préventive, mais
dede la justice réparatrice quia
jujusqu'à la vengeance, c'est ps
dadans la culture canadienne.
- - C'est pour cela qu'on dit,
dadans le fond, derrière tout ç,
c'c'est une question de valeur.
C'C'est très important,
çaça définit qui nous somme,
auaussi, comme Canadiens.
- - Oui c'est ça, d'ailleurs,
lala Cour suprême utilise cette
exexpression-là. C'est une valer
fofondamentale que le respect de
lala dignité des citoyens,
ququ'ils soient malades ou qu'is
sosoient détenus. Et rappelons-
nonous que l'expectative de vie
nonormale des citoyens pour
leles hommes; 81 ans, pour
leles femmes; 82 ans. Ça tombe
àà 60 ans chez les personnes
ququi sont détenues. Donc, si vs
vovoulez dire : "Bien, écoutez,
çaça vaut la peine de continuer
àà vous battre en détention
popour survivre et ne pas
vovous déprimer, et ne pas vous
susuicider, bien, pensez qu'au
bobout de 25 ans, il y aura
pepeut-être de la lumière au bot
dudu tunnel.
- - Sinon c'est l'équivalent
d'd'une peine de mort morale,
fifinalement.
MaMais si i on regarde, Me Hébe,
fifinalement, les gens que ça pt
afaffecter, parce qu'on comprend
bibien le principe. Il y a
dedes criminels actuellement
ququi ont reçu ces peines
cucumulatives, alors on envoie
ququelques-uns à l'écran : Justn
BoBourque, M. Garland aussi, ily
enen a d'autres aussi, Benjamin
HuHudon-Barbeau. Des gens qui ot
rereçu des peines très longues,
mamais là, ils vont devoir faire
unune demande pour qu'on révise
leleur peine?
- - Absolulument, au bout de 25,
ilils auront une demande à
foformuler. Et encore là,
ilils seront jugés sur la qualié
dedes dossiers qu'ils vont
prprésenter à la Commission des
lilibérations conditionnelles.
IlIl faut comprendre qu'il n'y a
papas d'automatismes. C'est pas
paparce que vous avez fait 25 as
quque, là, ça va bien, vous allz
êêtre libéré, il faudra beaucoup
plplus que ça pour convaincre
ceces gens-là qu'ils méritent
dede retourner dans la société.
- - Merci pour cette analyse
MeMe Hébert.
- - Merci, au revoir